[Aplausos]
hola como estan seguro no tan nerviosos
como yo pero les vengo a contar por qué
estoy aquí y como terminé en este
escenario todo empezó cuando use mi
cuenta de twitter para contarle a la
gente un secreto así que les dije y
saben que yo no compro ropa nueva bueno
a excepción de mi ropa interior e inés
traje de baño por obvias razones pero
bueno la ropa nueva no es algo
imprescindible de hecho en el mundo se
fabrican en promedio cada año 20 prendas
para cada persona que existen así que
desde hace 5 años yo me visto solamente
con ropa usado y eso bueno usada
reciclada ropa americana como quieran
llamar y eso no debería ser un secreto
pero tiene tantos estereotipos alrededor
que estoy terminó causando brewer
siguiendo con el tuit muchas personas
comenzaron a responderme y a contarme
que ellos también lo hacían pero que les
daba un poco de vergüenza admitirlo
otras personas me pidieron tips para
también hacerlo y por último hubo gente
que me envió fotos de sus outfits
también hechos con ropa de segunda así
que se me ocurrió hacer una cuenta donde
publicamos esos outfits y antes de todo
quiero contarles porque yo terminé
comprando ropa de segunda porque
continúa haciéndolo y porque hablo del
tema
cuando bueno todo empezó cuando vine de
san carlos es una zona rural a estudiar
acá a la universidad en san jose y
aumentaron los gastos y tenía
presupuesto de estudiante un presupuesto
que se alcanza para fotocopias libros
comida y pasajes del bus así que pues
bueno así empecé por motivos económicos
porque el presupuesto es urgente no
alcanzado para ropa nueva y me gustaba
mucho
y la moda y de hecho creo que incluso
podemos llegar a expresarnos a través de
cómo nos vestimos así que limpieza esto
y al parecer a mucha gente le gustó y
empecé a investigar muchísimo al
respecto sobre la industria textil
porque porque me di cuenta que lo que yo
estaba haciendo era reutilizando y
aunque era tal vez el vestido o el
desecho de otra persona empecé a
plantearme la ropa como basura alguna
vez se han planteado que la ropa es
basura así que le dije qué tipo de
basura es esta o cuánto puedo durar en
descomponerse luego de mucho rato
investigando me di cuenta del enorme
impacto socioambiental de la industria
textil lo contaminante y lo poco justa
que podría ser así me di cuenta que por
ejemplo una prenda de poliéster puede
tardar hasta 200 años en descomponerse
y que si el poliéster se introdujo como
fibra textil por primera vez en 1941
quiero decir que la primera prenda de
poliéster que se creó en el mundo aún
existe y está por ahí tratando de
descomponerse también me di cuenta que
cuando usaba un par de jeans también
llevaba puestos 7 mil 700 litros de agua
que es lo que consume sólo un jeans
durante todo su ciclo de vida así que
cuando el presupuesto de estudiante
mejoró y ya podía comprar ropa nueva
decidí no hacer uno porque soy un poco
tacaño acá entre nos dos porque decidí
que ya había suficiente ropa y que
utilizando ropa iba a ser la manera
bueno una de las maneras como yo iba a
disminuir mi impacto en el ambiente
porque era el reciclaje y se llama
reciclaje textil
aunque tenía muchísimos motivos
económicos sociales ambientales e
incluso feministas para reutilizar la
ropa mucha gente comenzó a cuestionarme
y peor aun intentaron avergonzarme
provecho de comprar ropa de segunda y es
que existen muchos estereotipos
posiblemente ustedes están haciendo
preguntas sobre el la ropa que yo paso
en este momento y pues si todos de ropa
usada
esther moñito que tengo aquí en el
cuello y entonces tuve que ir
argumentando y descartando cada uno de
los prejuicios que la gente tenía desde
que si era feo que estaba todo pasado de
moda que si no me daba asco que no se
era ropa de muertos que teníamos la
vibra hay todos juntos de cosas que
dicen así que bueno usado no significa
necesariamente que sea feo o de mala
calidad y eso lo demostré el día que
comencé a recrear outfits de famosas o
fashion bloggers pero todo con ropa
usado
con un presupuesto de menos de 10 mil
colones y cuando ando muy atrevida lo
hago por menos de 5 mil dólares eso otra
vez lo triple y se volvió un tweet
bastante popular al punto que termine en
la portada de un periódico nacional con
letras gigantes y me pusieron vistiendo
de ropa americana pero bueno eso fue
algo muy gracias pero a través de eso
pudo demostrar que no podía decir bien
que estaba ahorrando plata que no podía
ver a la moda y que de paso estaba
reciclando
bueno ahí tienen el tuit
a través de eso
me di cuenta que muchas personas se
identificaron con esto otra vez
comenzaron a aplicarme un montón de
fotos de gente haciendo lo mismo y
motivando sé hacerlo y es que es justo
eso identificarse con una acción que
tenga un impacto positivo y ver cómo
poco a poco puedo llevarlo a la práctica
cuando la gente me dice cómo no pero vos
no andas así como siempre en súper pasa
de moda con usar ropa vieja pues en
realidad queda difícil es llevarle el
ritmo de la moda actualmente
la tendencia a la industria textil
cambio hasta 20 años pasamos de tener un
modelo con cuatro tendencias
estacionales al año a tener un modelo
fast fashion o de moda rápido este
modelo
nos da micro tendencias y colecciones
nuevas cada dos semanas es decir que si
cada dos semanas no le agregan una
prenda nueva en sus clases posiblemente
de servín pero están pasados de moda
como yo
así que esto nos dice algo cada dos
semanas se están creando prendas nuevas
pero también se están creando se están
botando toneladas de basura textil de
ropa
este modelo fast fashion trata
justamente de hacernos creer que estamos
comprando ropa barata y de hecho sí pero
estamos comprando mucho más ropa pero
esa ropa se volvió desechable así que es
de mala calidad y tenemos que votarla
pronto
fue así como me di cuenta que por
ejemplo para fabricar víveres como el
poliéster el expand ex de nylon se
necesitan 70 millones de barriles de
petróleo al año y lamento contarles que
el 85 por ciento de toda la
contaminación micro plástica de los
océanos proviene del lavado doméstico de
prendas sintéticas
cada vez que lavamos una sola prenda de
poliéster se desprenden 1900 microfibras
que llegan al océano directamente porque
son tan pequeñas que los filtros de las
aguas de tratamientos residuales no la
pueden retener
además para fabricar prendas de rayón o
de mis cosas que necesitan pagar 70
millones de árboles al año y el cultivo
del algodón es el responsable del 24 y
el 11 por ciento de todos los pesticidas
e insecticidas a nivel mundial
por todo esto fue que creé esta cuenta
pero además decidió utilizarla no solo
para subir fotos de outfits o de tips
sino que dije eso hacer también una
plataforma donde voy a subir información
y donde podamos informarnos y aprender
sobre el impacto de la industria textil
por qué porque identifique que había un
vacío sobre este tema y haga más de vida
notifique que habían personas que
querían empezar a hacer un poco más
conscientes y responsables a la hora de
comprar
yo elegí no utilizar ropa nueva y voy a
utilizar ropa sin embargo les voy a
hablar de algunas soluciones que según
sus contextos y posibilidades ustedes
pueden emplear la primera no comprar lo
que no necesito de verdad necesitamos
toda la ropa que está en nuestro
proyecto
la segunda comprar prendas nacionales
por qué porque traer prendas desde el
exterior imito demasiadas emisiones en
cuanto a transporte o sea cómo llega
algo desde china hasta costa rica así
que comprar local estamos apoyando el
diseñador nacional y nos estamos
hablando un montón de energía y
combustibles luego prendas sustentables
eso quiere decir que sean fabricadas con
materiales amigables con el ambiente o
bien que garanticen el trato justo con
las personas que la fabrican
también aprendo de segunda ya les he
hablado mucho de eso y otra cosa que
podemos hacer es alquilar o pedir
prestado para que comprar algo que solo
vamos a usar una vez también es
importante cuidar los ciclos de lavado
porque se gasta muchísima agua y energía
cuando lo hacemos y por último qué tal
reparar y no botar absolutamente todo
cuando se jode ya podríamos tal vez
llevarle un poco de trabajo a la
costurera del barrio o volver a esa
etapa por ejemplo de muchos de nuestros
padres donde iban al sastre o donde la
modista a que le confeccionaron ropa a
la medida y bueno como país que tenemos
que hacer definitivamente necesitamos
políticas públicas que traten sobre el
tratamiento adecuado de residuos
textiles porque no las hay
necesitamos centros de acopio textil y
vienen campañas que incentiven el
reciclaje textil tiene que ser una de
nuestros métodos como país ambientalista
la industria de la moda necesita un
cambio de narrativa una que incluya el
impacto ambiental y humano de la cadena
textil nos están vendiendo un montón de
ropa que es desechable y eso no se trata
de un boicot a la industria textil esto
no se trata de venir y sembrar fábricas
y dejar a un montón de gente sin trabajo
eso se trata de transformar la industria
textil y por supuesto de transformar
también nuestros hábitos de consumo nos
están vendiendo un montón de ropa que es
tendencia hoy pero que mañana o en dos
semanas como les conté va a ser basura
así que no necesitamos tanta ropa ya
existe muchísima ropa en el mundo y creo
que definitivamente la prenda más
sostenible es la prenda que ya existe y
gracias
[Aplausos]